hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about bunions what can you do for a
bunions okay so we have our lovely
demonstrator or guinea pig I mean
patient that we're going to demonstrate
this on so let's have you man your back
so we have these these this is a bunion
okay she has two of them unfortunately
so these are calcium deposits and the
problem is you never want to press on
them because it's going to make it worse
so what I'm going to show you to do is
if they hurt what to do now normally if
she had a bunion just on one side all we
would do is press on the opposite side
and press and stimulate that and that
will get rid of the pain right here but
that's not going to work because she has
it on both sides so the only thing we
can do is work on the opposite of the
bunion which happens to be right in
there okay
so when I take my thumb and you could do
this to yourself this is the big toe
this bone right here and we can press on
the inside going this way so that is
going to be a little sore yeah so she's
telling me yes so I'm pressing right
into this point right through here
because that's the opposite of the
bunion and what will happen it's going
to give her relief and even if we don't
get rid of the bunion if we get rid of
the pain then who cares if you have a
bunion right so the main thing is being
able wear shoes and not have it hurt so
right in there we're coming and we're
working in the opposite and I can do
both sides at the same time so pressing
on the inside right through here and I
will say it will be very tender on the
inside right through here so you got to
go light but this is the point that you
press never press on the bunion it's
just on the inside the toe inward
towards the bunion going this side right
through here so we'll do this side right
here and we just stimulate it for about
a minute
this side right here what's going to
happen is when she stands up she's not
going to feel any more pain anymore so
that's what you do to relieve the pain
from a bunion so go ahead and try this
and put your comments below I'll see you
the next video